estamos en el problema número 10 así que
vamos a ver qué dice carlos usa cuatro
piezas de cinta adhesiva cada una de 6
pulgadas de largo para pegar un póster
ok vamos a poner eso para un póster ok
carlos usac cuatro pedazos de cinta
adhesiva cuatro pedazos de cinta
adhesiva y cada uno a ver paso por los
cuatro pedazos ok y cada uno de 6
pulgadas de largo 4 pedazos de 6
pulgadas las pulgadas de largo pulgadas
si carlos empezó con 300 pies o keith y
eso es importante empezó con 300 pies
con 300 pies pero además nos dicen que
aquí está dado en pulgadas y aquí está
dado en pies creo que tarde o temprano
vamos a necesitar un cambio de unidades
si carlos empezó con 300 pies de cinta
adhesiva y además no se desperdicia nada
de cinta adhesiva cuál de los siguientes
incisos representan el número de pies y
esto lo subrayan el número de pies es
decir nuestros resultados tiene que
estar en pies ok que queda después de
pegar en el póster es ok lo que me
preguntan es cuantos pies después de
pegar en el póster es post
eres perfecto y además me dan el
siguiente dato 12 pulgadas es un pie eso
lo vamos a ocupar
12 pulgadas pulgadas
es lo mismo que un pie ok y eso en el
caso de que tengas un piel normal y
bueno como resolvemos este problema
tenemos muchos datos que te parece si
primero pensamos en los n pósteres y es
más antes de pensar en los n pósteres
vamos a pensar cuánta cinta adhesiva
gastamos si nosotros queremos pegar un
póster si nosotros queremos pegar un
póster ocupamos 4 pedazos de 6 pulgadas
pero esto es exactamente lo mismo que
cuatro pedazos pedazos de iu en lugar de
ponerlo como 6 pulgadas voy a
transformar esto de pulgadas a pies
porque el resultado tiene que estar en
pies entonces cuánto es 6 pulgadas
empieza
bueno pues usan está regla de 36
pulgadas pulgadas debe equivaler a pues
la mitad de un pie a un medio de pie
esto sale de la regla de 3 muy sencilla
entonces cuatro pedazos de medio pie de
un medio de pie esto para pegar un
póster pero si nosotros queremos pegar n
pósteres vamos a tener n postres y bueno
para cada uno de estos vamos a ocupar
cuatro pedazos cuatro pedazos y cada uno
de estos pedazos es de un medio de pie
cada uno de estos pedazos es de un medio
de pie y bueno si te das cuenta esto es
lo mismo que dos en ok dos n es la
cantidad de pies que nosotros vamos a
gastar de cinta canela para pegar n
pósteres ok pero si inicialmente
empezamos con 300 pies entonces lo que
nos va a quedar después de pegar en el
póster es después 300 que fue con lo que
empezamos ya esto le voy a quitar la
cantidad en pieza que nosotros nos
gastamos de pegar en el póster es que es
es la cantidad de pies de cinta adhesiva
que nosotros nos gastamos para pegar en
el póster es por lo tanto 300 menos 2 n
es la cantidad de cinta adhesiva que me
va a quedar que es justo lo que me
preguntan cuál de los siguientes incisos
representa el número de pies de cinta
adhesiva que queda después de pegar en
el poste de 300 menos 2 n que por cierto
es el inciso b así que de lujo ya está
vamos a hacer el siguiente problema
déjame quitar esto y déjame poner aquí
el problema número 11 el problema número
11 que me dice lo siguiente en el plano
x y en la recta m es la reflexión de la
línea l de la renta l bajo el eje x si
la recta m tiene una pendiente de menos
cuatro quintos ok la pendiente vamos a
poner aquí
m tiene pendiente tiene pendiente
pendiente de menos cuatro quintos de
menos cuatro quintos ok
cuál es la pendiente de la recta l lo
que me preguntan es la pendiente de la
recta l y esta es una de las preguntas
que tarde o temprano iban a aparecer en
nuestras vidas así que déjame hacer aquí
el trato cartesiano voy a decir que este
es el eje de ayer por acá y es más desde
el ponerlo por acá por acá tengo al eje
x ok y bueno realmente también dicen
cuánto vale la ordenada el origen de
esta recta m ni tampoco de la recta l
este es el eje y este es el eje x pero
tenemos una pendiente de menos cuatro
quintos
así que sin pérdida de generalidad vamos
a anclar la en el origen ok y déjame
poner aquí un poco de unidades para que
te vayas ubicando aquí tengo uno
23 45 por acá voy a hacer 1 2 3 4 es
decir es que estamos en el 4 positivo en
que estamos en el 5 en x y por acá tengo
1234 aquí tenemos en el menos cuatro en
diez así que vamos a aclarar el origen y
si yo pienso en la recta m la recta m
tiene una pendiente de menos cuatro
quintos es decir que por cada 5 que
nosotros caminemos en x recuerda que
esto es el cambio en x a comparación del
cambio en game por cada cinco que
nosotros caminemos en x vamos a bajar 4
en 10 o sea que este caminamos 5 en x
vamos a bajar 4 en james por acá está mi
otro punto de esta misma recta y si
tenemos 2 puntos podemos trazar por aquí
más o menos por aquí no no no me gustó
nada podemos pasar por aquí mi recta
esta va a ser mi recta
ok esta es mi recta m pero me dice que
la recta l es la reflexión de esta recta
m bajo el eje x lo que quiere decir que
este punto este punto del origen no va a
dejar tal cual ok pero a este punto lo
va a reflejar para acá en el eje x ya
está esta parte de la veta la va a
reflejar para acá
ok como encuentro mi recta l bueno pues
si te das cuenta este punto que está en
el 5 menos 4 en el 5 menos 4 ahora me lo
va a mandar con el mismo ángulo para acá
es decir que va a llegar al punto 5,4 al
5,4 de tal manera que esta parte quede
reflejada aquí y si ya tengo otro punto
entonces puedo visualizar a esta recta
como esta recta de aquí como esta recta
que va a pasar por estos dos puntos y va
a continuar así hasta el infinito lo que
quiero que veas es que si es la
reflexión de esta recta de azul entonces
estos dos ángulos tanto este ángulo
como este ángulo deben de ser iguales y
por lo tanto lo único que estamos
cambiando es pasar de este punto que
tengo aquí a este punto que tengo acá y
para cualquier par de rectas
yo no podría tomar por ejemplo aquí a un
eje aquí a otro eje tal vez no corten en
el origen que te parece si una recta se
ve más o menos así vamos a pensar en
esta recta de aquí y entonces mi recta
reflejada bajo el eje de las x se va a
ver más o menos así es decir va a tener
el mismo ángulo que se va a formar con
el eje de las equis y así podemos pensar
en una recta también muy inclinada y le
va a pasar lo mismo por lo tanto si yo
quiero hablar de la pendiente de la
recta l esta es mi recta l 11 déjame
cambiar la herramienta esta es mi recta
l pues entonces va a tener como
pendiente la pendiente de la recta l va
a ser igual a am si empezamos en el
origen o caminamos sin fue en x y
subimos 4 en 10 por lo tanto va a ser
cuatro quintos y ahora con signo
positivo lo único que va a cambiar es
el signo de la pendiente y ya está la
respuesta es el inciso b que es cuatro
quintos justo esto que tengo aquí de
lujo lo único que pasa cuando reflejamos
rectas bajo el eje x es que las
pendientes cambian de signo ok
problema número 11 vamos a hacer el
problema número 12 borramos la pantalla
del problema número 12 dice si n si y es
el problema número 12 si n es igual a 3
p
para que pep para que el valor de p en
es igual a p eso suena muy raro primero
nos dice que en el estrés veces p y
después nos pregunta para qué valor de p
n es igual a p pues eso podrá ser cierto
parece que nunca si yo tengo que n es
igual al triple de p pues nunca va a ser
siempre va a ser el triple de p a ver
veamos los incisos
claro claro claro ya soy encontrando el
número más bien sin parar
ningún número excepto uno pasa que n es
igual porque n siempre es el triple del
pp pero hay un número que si lo cumple
puedes imaginarte cuál a qué pasa cuando
p vale
0 cuando te vale 0 pues 3 x 0 es 0 n
vale 0 y es el único caso si tú puedes
cualquier otro caso para p pues en nueva
manera el triple es el número pero el
triple cero es una trampa es cero
también por lo tanto p igual a cero es
mi respuesta del problema número 12
hasta estuvo muy fácil así que vamos a
hacer aquí el problema número 13 que
tiene unas rectas parecidas a éstas
tengo una recta si tengo una recta por
acá y tengo otra recta por acá algo así
ok y me dan algunos ángulos así que
vamos a ponerlos me dicen que este es x
esta es la recta el ay esta es la recta
m esta es la recta l este es el ángulo
y este es el ángulo z es el ángulo z que
por cierto me dicen que vale 30 grados
este ángulo vale 30 grados ok y lo que
me preguntan es cuánto vale x + y bueno
pues esto parece como el juego de los
ángulos es muy parecido el juego de los
ángulos vamos a ver si lo podemos
resolver
mira aquí tenemos una cosa muy
importante quiero que te fijes en este
triángulo este trago no es la clave de
este problema la suma de todos los
ángulos internos de un triángulo deben
de sumar 180 grados por lo tanto dime
cómo podemos escribir este ángulo de
aquí bueno pues este ángulo de aquí es
suplementario allí y si este ángulo es
suplementario james entonces su medida
sería pues 180 menos bien la medida de
este ángulo es 180 menos bien de tal
manera que si sumamos estos dos me da
180 y de igual manera para este cual es
la medida de este ángulo bueno pues la
medida de este ángulo es y aquí tengo x
la suma de estos dos le da 180 y por lo
tanto este ángulo son más 180 menos x
este ángulo tiene el valor más bien de
180 menos x está en 1 vale x este vale
180 menos 10 y esteller porque son
suplementarios y éste nos dice que vale
30 grados
y para que esto porque yo sé que la suma
de estos tres ángulos que están adentro
de este triángulo deben de sumar 180 es
decir que la suma de éste de 180 menos x
si a esto le sumó este otro que vale 180
menos 180 menos 10 es este de aquí este
de aquí ok y si a esto le sumó el ángulo
z pero el ángulo z vale 30 grados esto
la suma de estos tres porque está dentro
de un triángulo es 180 grados esto es lo
mismo que 180 grados y qué te parece si
de aquí despejamos y vamos a despejar un
poco este se puede ir con este 180 más
30 es 210 y me quedaría que 210 menos x
menos esto es igual a cero este lo
cancelé con este estos dos los une estos
dos los sume y me queda esto y sigue
aquí pasó esta x del otro lado de la
ecuación y está ya del otro lado de la
ecuación para buscar x más
quedar bueno pues me va a quedar que x
y pasan con signo contrario estoy
sumando x de ambos lados de esta
ecuación y estoy sumando bien de ambos
lados de esta ecuación x + es lo mismo
que 210 grados que es justo lo que me
pedían el valor de x magem es 210 grados
que era justo lo que estaba buscando y
por cierto es el inciso de la respuesta
a este problema número 13 es el inciso
de hasta el siguiente vídeo